high school you started dealing with
that yeah i got sent to military school
i got kicked out of high school
and my parents didn't know what to do to
me dude with me or to me i i added a
little taste for the booze in high
school i loved
when i was a freshman two seniors took
me out and got me drunk
and it changed my life it made me not
shy
i talked to girls i would kiss girls i
was like alcohol is amazing
and i really took taboos and like i
became an alcoholic
i don't want to say alcohol holic
because i literally stopped
when i was like 18 or 19 was like i
think i'm done
and i never had an urge really i just
knew that when i was
a teenager and shy and terrified of
talking to people
that got me through it but
i really
leaned heavily on it
and so my parents didn't know what to do
with me so they sent me to military
school
the school where they filmed taps valley
forge military academy wayne
pennsylvania
and um they straighten you up
straighten you out
you know
in high school i was i favored the booze
when i went to military school
you're subject to daily inspections
because it's like the military right and
so it became a lot easier to hide drugs
in your well so you started doing drugs
in military school yeah mostly like weed
and like mushrooms
right and so you weren't powdering your
nose or anything no i tried all that
stuff but it i didn't like it
i liked hallucinogenics and we i left
weed and
you know hash
um
but uh i remember specifically one day
in military school i was walking down
the hallway in the dorm
two of my friends were wrestling they
were play wrestling and one of one of
the guys lifted up the other one off his
feet and they both fell backwards
and
one of the guys hit his head on the
corner of a cinderblock doorway and
split his head wide open
and i can still see it to this day in my
head like you know
barracks and stuff in the military it's
all that lime green
so i just remember the stark contrast of
bright red blood coming out of this
guy's head onto a lime green floor like
it is burned into my mind
and later that night i was
at dinner and i was eating my food and
all of a sudden i couldn't swallow
like
and that's not a memory reflex that's
like an involuntary like
it's like breathing you shouldn't have
to think you don't think about
swallowing and all of a sudden i
couldn't swallow and i was trying to
make myself sweat and i couldn't i was
having what i later
years later figured out was a panic
attack it just that's how it manifests
and you think it was because that
triggered it seeing all the blood and
everything that's what triggered it i
think that that at 17 years old was the
first time i realized
oh i'm gonna die someday
and it doesn't matter if i'm
80 which i hope that's you know much
later i hope i die when i'm much later
but
i could die when i'm 17
and it really kicked everything off for
me as far as
my big problem has always been uh panic
and anxiety disorder right
mixed with some depression and it
started there
you